sie schlagen scheiben ein
sie werfen flaschen auf polizisten fünf
beamte werden verletzt
500 bis 800 randalierer sorgen auf dem
opernplatz und frankfurt am vergangenen
wochenende für ausnahmezustände
umherstehende personen jubeln und
klatschen soweit flaschen auf die
beamten treffen die polizei ist zunächst
machtlos
nur mit verstärkung der bundespolizei
kann die situation unter kontrolle
gebracht werden
stadt und polizei auf dieser strecke
bilder reagiert sperrstunde ab 1 uhr
dann soll der opernplatz geräumt sein
werden sich die gewalttätigen szenen
wiederholen
die polizei vorbereitet und überwacht
den opernplatz aus ganz hessen rückt die
bereitschaftspolizei nach frankfurt an
um nur wer die allgemeinverfügung in der
stadt mit lautsprechern vorgelesen
zwei thw lichtmasten mit grellem
scheinwerferlicht strahlenden platz aus
50 minuten später ist der opa platz
geräumt dieses mal fliegen keine
flaschen eine positive bilanz der
polizei die zu solchen maßnahmen greifen
muss um randale zu verhindern sind die
probleme damit gelöst oder verlagert
sich die randalen an andere stellen die
stadt versucht gemeinsam mit betreibern
ein alternativkonzept zu entwickeln
möglich wären sogenannte kultursommer
gärten an vier öffentlichen flächen ab
mitte august bis mitte september
vielleicht eine möglichkeit um solche
krawalle in zukunft zu verhindern
[Applaus]
und in der nacht dabei war meine
kollegin lisa gül hat lisa wir haben
eben die bilder gesehen die polizei sagt
es lief alles friedlich ab wie war die
stimmung in dieser nacht in frankfurt
also die stimmung ist nicht zu
vergleichen gewesen mit dem was jetzt am
letzten wochenende hier passiert ist
die leute waren sehr ruhig es waren auch
sehr sehr wenige leute anwesend also es
waren fast mehr kamerateams und beamte
hier vor ort als das jetzt hier feiernde
gewesen wären viele scheinen auch
einfach nur schaulustige gewesen zu sein
die einfach wissen wollten nachdem das
alles durch die medien ging was hier
vorgefallen ist um sich hier mal vor ort
anzusehen was hier überhaupt ist es war
ein familien
es waren jugendliche auch aus der gegend
die sich hier eingefunden haben
studenten die sich hier ganz ruhig in
gruppen zusammen hier hingesetzt haben
einen hirschen getrunken haben und
einfach beobachten haben wie sich die
situation entwickelt aber das waren bis
kurz vor 22 uhr eigentlich nicht mal
knapp 100 leute und die beamten wir
haben schon ab 20 uhr immer wieder
kleine gruppen von 19 riecht regelrecht
eingekesselt und eine personenkontrolle
durchgeführt also sobald dann diese
personen ausgemacht wurden kamen auch
dann direkt über ein dutzend beamte
zusammen und haben sich um diese
personen herum gestellt was dann so vier
bis sechs leute nur waren umzingelt von
bis zu 16 beamten und haben diese
kontrolle durchgeführt damit sich da
auch keine brisante situation ergeben
konnte und bei der räumung da lief dann
auch alles ganz geregelt ab da wurden
die scheinwerfer eingestellter fuhren
direkt die räumungs fahrzeuge auch in
die menge herein und es wurden immer
wieder lautsprecher durchsagen gemacht
da kam es eigentlich zu keinen
zwischenfällen
lisa wie sieht denn das
sicherheitskonzept der stadt aus soll
jetzt jedes wochenende der opernplatz
von der polizei geräumt werden ja also
die informationen die wir jetzt haben
und wie es in der verordnung vorgesehen
ist soll auf jeden fall das ende des
sommers also bis zum september soll hier
mit einem
grossaufgebot immer abends hier geräumt
und gesperrt werden
das ist natürlich ein sehr personal
aufwendiges unterfangen
hier stand nämlich gestern nicht nur am
opernplatz beamte an etwaigen ecken
immer mindestens grüppchen von vier
beamten dann natürlich an verschiedenen
straßen auch polizeiwagen wo weitere
beamten drin warteten die bei einer
brisanten situation natürlich sofort
hätten eingreifen können und dann damit
sich eben die menge nicht dann auf
andere plätze verlagerten wurden auch
andere große plätze wie eben die
hauptwache zb auch von ganz vielen
beamten bewacht und andere haben einen
bereitschaftsdienst in ihren
polizeiwagen gemacht um eben in so einem
fall eingreifen zu können
auch das mainufer wurde verstärkt
überwacht und das wählen die polizei
hier in frankfurt bis zum ende des
sommers durchziehen